Verhandlungen die Frühjahrsoffensive mit
oder ohne Einsatz von Kampfjet Jets was
wird den Krieg in der Ukraine
entscheiden Präsident selensky warb in
Berlin London und Paris um mehr
Unterstützung militärisch aber er warb
auch erneut um die Aufnahme in EU und
NATO die Niederlande und Großbritannien
planen eine internationale Koalition für
Kampfjets für Deutschland ist das die
rote Linie die nicht überschritten
werden soll und auch die USA sind
zurückhaltend aus Angst vor einer
weiteren Eskalation durch Russland Krieg
gegen die Ukraine wann kommt der
Wendepunkt unser Thema in der Phönix
Runde
guten Abend ich begrüße Sie ganz
herzlich aus Berlin und darf in meine
Gäste vorstellen Prof dr Carlo Masala
ist bei uns Militärexperte Professor für
internationale Politik an der
Universität der Bundeswehr in München
und auch Mitglied im wissenschaftlichen
Beirat der Bundesakademie für
Sicherheitspolitik ich begrüße bei
namika Chef Publizistin und ehemalige
Chefredakteurin der Frankfurter
Rundschau und davor der taz Christian
Maria Label ist bei uns Sprecherin von
vite eV das ist eine Vereinigung junger
Ukraine und Ukrainerinnen in Deutschland
die Hilfe für Flüchtlinge und auch
Solidarität für die Ukraine organisiert
Prof dr Alexander Liebmann Professor für
Politikwissenschaft mit Schwerpunkt
Osteuropa und Russland an der Freien
Universität Berlin herzlich willkommen
Herr Masala jetzt hat gerade der
ukrainische Präsident selenski an diesem
Wochenende ja mehrere europäische
Hauptstädte besucht und hat um mehr
Waffen gebeten jetzt hören wir diese
Ankündigung von einer möglichen
Koalition zwischen Niederlande
Großbritannien für Kampfjets
das bewerten ist das ein Zeichen dass
dieser Krieg doch noch viel weiter
eskaliert nein es ist ja keine
Eskalation also wir liefern ja im Staat
der sich verteidigt Waffen damit er sich
noch besser verteidigen kann deswegen
ist das kein eskalatorischer Schritt man
muss aber dazu sagen es ist erstmal die
Ankündigung dieser Staaten auf F16 zu
trainieren es gibt noch keinen Staat der
sich dazu verpflichtet hat F16 zu
liefern die USA sind weiterhin sehr
zurückhaltend von den USA letzten Endes
hängt es auch davon ab dass F16
überhaupt geliefert werden kann
Großbritannien selber hat gar keine F16
die Niederlande eine begrenzte Zahl also
ich glaube auch da könnten sie nicht so
viel abgeben und und Frankreich
sozusagen trainiert auf es F16 hat aber
selber wie gesagt auch keine F16 es ist
erstmal eine Koalition für Training so
muss man das sehen aber das Training
dauert vier bis sechs Monate ungefähr
lange aber es ist ja so ein starkes
Symbol auch weil das war immer so ein
Punkt gerade auch in Deutschland immer
gesagt hat das auf keinen Fall also wie
bewerten sie denn sozusagen das
symbolisch auch symbolisch ist es
wichtig weil es sozusagen aber das hat
mir schon seit Lieferungen die
Schützenpanzer und dann der Kampfpanzer
wo ganz klar vormals selbst definierte
rote Linien einfach gefallen worden sind
und dann ab dem Zeitpunkt war klar wir
werden auch ernsthaft irgendwann mal
über Kampfjets reden müssen weil die
militärisch Sinn machen und für die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland das ist ja
keine rote Linie in dem Sinne weil es
war ja Olaf Scholz der vor ein paar
Wochen den Polen den rehexport der mit
29 in die Ukraine genehmigt hat also das
heißt zwar altes sowjetische Kampfjets
aber für die ukrainische Luftwaffe neue
Kampfjets zu bekommen damit hat
Deutschland im Prinzip ja die Tür
aufgestoßen in dieser ganzen Kampfjet
Sebastian Debatte die jetzt
weitergeführt wird wir selber werden uns
nicht daran beteiligen weil wir den
Eurofighter haben das ist ein ganz
anderes Modell und das würde die Ukraine
sozusagen voll logistische
Herausforderungen stellen
rote Linie mit den Eintrag gesagt hat
was heißt denn das für sie wenn wenn
jetzt Großbritannien und niederländische
sagen eventuell könnte man könnten wir
da trainieren was bedeutet wie bewerten
sie das also ich finde Herr Marcela was
sie sagen ist nichts als schönrede dabei
selbstverständlich ist das eine
Eskalation in diesem Krieg und nicht
umsonst wurde immer wieder gesagt das
ist eine rote Linie und deswegen
beteiligt sich auch die Bundesregierung
nicht daran das hat sie auch ganz
deutlich gesagt sogar Frau stark
Zimmermann von der FDP die ja ansonsten
eher dafür bekannt ist dass sie sich am
liebsten selbst in Panzer setzen würde
um in die Ukraine
transportiert zu werden also
mit Kampfjets die eben keine reinen
Verteidigungswaffen sind gut das sind
die Leopards auch schon nicht das war ja
auch schon ein eine reine
Verteidigungswaffe müssen mal nach 15
Monaten Krieg mit diesem Mythos aufhören
das ist definitiv und offensive
vielleicht lassen sie mich mal ausreden
klar es gibt Waffen die hauptsächlich
zur Verteidigung genutzt werden können
und nicht besonders gut taugen zum
Angriff und es gibt andere die Tauben
hervorragend zum Angriff und dazu gehört
gehören Kampfjets und deswegen ist es
selbstverständlich eine Eskalationsstufe
und die Vorstellung dass damit der Krieg
auf russischen Boden getragen werden
kann ist finde ich eine wirklich
erschreckende Vorstellung dann ist es
ein anderer Krieg darf ich ganz gut zwei
Sachen sagen ich würde ganz gerne erst
die beiden anderen kurz in die
Diskussion einsetzen was würden Sie denn
sagen wenn das jetzt so wäre also
welches Signal ist das in Richtung
Russland die Lieferung oder auch schon
das Training von ukrainischen Soldaten
Soldaten auf den kartenchefswert
tatsächlich aus boscover sich nicht so
viel bedeuten solange kann Chaps nicht
geliefert werden das ist das
entscheidende falls aber die Kampfjet
tatsächlich geliefert wären da muss ich
leider zustimmen ich sehe die Situation
nicht sehr gefährlich es wird einfach
dazu dass die Ukraine deutlich größere
Möglichkeiten bekommen kann die Ziele
auf die russischen Territorium oder auf
der Halbinsel Grimm aktiv anzugreifen
sobald der Krieg auf dem russischen
Territorium massiv ablaufen wird werden
wir und das müssen wir ganz ehrlich sein
uns leider auf einen sehr dünnen Eis
bewegen die Benutzung von weiteren
Eskalationsstufen seitens Russlands und
es geht da zum Beispiel massiver weitere
Angriffe gegen zivile Ziele um Angriffe
gegen nato-objekte möglicherweise oder
auch
schlimmereskalationspotenziale die wir
alle kennen wird dann nicht mehr durch
militärisch Logiken bestimmt sondern
durch politische Überlebens also Krieg
auf dem russischen Boden muss
tatsächlich absolute Linie sein und ich
bin leider nicht überzeugt dass die
Lieferung von kampfscherz es tatsächlich
möglich machen wird diese rote Linie als
glaubwürdig zu behalten okay würde ich
gerne Frau lebe zu hören von lebe was
ist wie empfinden Sie diese Nachricht
das Großbritannien Niederlande das
eventuell tun als Koalition und auch das
Werben von selenski für die Kante was
bedeutet das für jemanden aus der
Ukraine wir haben uns sehr über diese
Ankündigung der Koalition gefreut als
ukrainische Zivilgesellschaft auch hier
in Deutschland aber auch die Leute vor
Ort weil für uns bedeuten
Waffenlieferung dass sich unsere
Familien unsere Freunde unsere
Angehörigen angemessen verteidigen
können wenn wir über Kampfjets reden
geht es darum dass die Ukraine ihre
Lufthoheit verteidigen kann dass sie
weniger Verluste auf ukrainische Seite
von Seiten der Soldaten hat dass sie
aber auch Raketen und Drohnen von
Russland besser abfangen kann und wir
sehen dass sich die Angriffe auf die
zivile auf die zivilen Ziele sozusagen
verstärkt haben wir haben jetzt im Mai
acht nächtliche Angriffe allein auf
Kiews gehabt das ist jeder zweite Tag
und da muss man sich vor Augen führen
dass diese Kampfjets eine wichtige Rolle
spielen würden in der Verteidigung und
in der Rückeroberung von ukrainischen
Territorium und deswegen sollte man das
nicht ausschließen sie hätten keine
Angst vor einer Eskalation die
Eskalation passiert ja schon jeden Tag
also wir haben Städte die komplett
ausradiert worden sind wir haben
Massengräber wir haben massende
portationen für die Ukraine gibt es
keine weitere Stufe der Eskalation
vielleicht können Sie mit wir wollten
noch darauf reagieren aber vielleicht
können Sie noch die eine Frage mit
beantworten wie die wie stark die
Ukraine jetzt militärisch im Moment da
steht
sie steht nicht übermäßig stark da also
alle warten auf diese Offensive die
Seiten ist der Ukraine sehr präzise
vorbereitet wird weil sozusagen sie hat
nicht viele Chancen viele offensiven zu
fahren das muss man ganz deutlich sagen
egal was er was der stellvertretender
Verteidigungsminister sagt über mehrere
Wellen von offensiven aber da gibt es
nicht mehr so viel Potenzial
sie hat wohl ungefähr 70.000 Mann
zusammen für diese offensiven wie gut
die sind wissen wir nicht wir wissen
nicht sozusagen wo diese offensiven
stattfinden werden sie
sag mal so dass die Ukraine sind deshalb
auch unter anderem so stark weil die
Russen so schlecht sind das muss man
ganz einfach sagen es ist eine Stärke
der der Armee die da ist die sehr
innovativ ist aber letzten Endes vieles
ist auch sozusagen der Schwäche der
russischen Armee zu schulden und das
klugen ausnutzens durch die ukrainische
Streitkräfte aber wenn ich noch was zu
F16 sagen darf weil das ist ich finde
das ist schon wichtig man muss sich mal
darüber unterhalten was will man
politisch
wenn man politisch dass die Ukraine in
der Lage ist diesen Krieg zu ihren
Gunsten zu entscheiden dann glaube ich
muss man sehr konsequent sein und sagen
man liefert der Ukraine alles was Sie
dafür braucht und dazu gehören halt auch
Kampfflugzeuge und wenn man es
militärisch jetzt mal betrachtet und
deswegen Kampfflugzeuge ja natürlich
kann die Ukraine mit einer F16 tief in
den russischen Luftraum vorstoßen eine
Bombe abwerfen die Frage ist warum
sollte sie das machen sie verliert
sofort sämtliche westliche Unterstützung
die Russen selber haben eine sozusagen
eine Luftverteidigung die durchaus in
der Lage wäre diese diese Kampfflugzeuge
abzuschießen so was besseres könnte den
Russen nicht passieren was macht man
aber mit der F16 auf dem Schlachtfeld
sie schützen Ihre eigenen Soldaten sie
können aus der Luft ihre vorrückenden
Verbände schützen und jetzt kommt der
Punkt und jetzt kommt sozusagen die
Eskalation sollte die russische
Luftwaffe in diesem Konflikt stärker
eingreifen als dies in der Vergangenheit
der Fall gewesen ist haben sie mit der F
16 die Möglichkeit sozusagen zu
verhindern dass sie Russen die Luft
hochhalten bekommen und wenn die lufthan
hat in einem Konflikt ist immer im
Vorteil auf dem Boden aber dann hätte
man das doch schon viel früher
liefern sollen aber man hat es nicht
getan aus politischen Gründen
dann müssen wir tatsächlich diese Logik
von sehr genau durchkalkulierten
Schachzügen auf beiden Seiten nicht
weiter so betrachten wir sind einfach
nicht sicher erstens wie die Waffen
benutzt werden sie werden auch von
einzelnen Piloten benutzt das sind auch
Menschen wir können da keine Garantie
dass keine von denen auch wenn es
Befehle geben wird in russischen
Luftraum nicht zu betreten das nicht
ignorieren wird und es gibt immer
Zwischenfälle es gibt unkalkulierte
Situationen und wer muss leider ganz
ehrlich sein natürlich ist die
Unterstützung der Ukraine ein
strategisches Ziel der Europäischen
Union der USA aber die Risiken der
militärischen Eskalation mit Russland
sind einfach so gravierend dass sie da
sehr gewichtige rote Linien bilden bei
denen man einfach vorsichtig sein muss
gibt es ja die Faktor Ukraine also von
Russland nicht und gemeinsam diese roten
Linien werden die ganze Zeit
selbstständig von der Bundesregierung
oder von anderen gesetzt Russland
kommuniziert diese rote Linien so nicht
und die Ukraine auch nicht also die
Ukraine ist in einem existenziellen
Überlebenskampf für die eigene
Staatlichkeit deswegen kann man da nicht
von roten Linien sprechen
völkerrechtlich hat sie das Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung
widersprechen da gebe ich Ihnen auch
völlig Recht und ich sie haben auch
völlig Recht wenn Sie sagen für die
Ukraine gibt es keine Eskalationsstufen
aber man muss auch sagen hier sind die
UnterstützerInnen der Ukraine und die
Ukraine nicht immer derselben Meinung da
gibt es unterschiedliche Interessenten
und das Interesse des Westens ist
natürlich die Ukraine zu unterstützen
damit sie sich verteidigen kann und
nicht einfach von den Russen überrollt
wird aber es kann nicht im Interesse des
Westens sein dass dieser Krieg zu einem
Krieg zwischen der Nato und Russland
wird und es ist sich selbstverständlich
und ich verstehe das sogar meiner
Meinung nach durchaus im Interesse der
der Ukraine genau aus diesem Grund den
sie sagen dass es für sie nämlich es
kann eigentlich kaum noch kaum noch
schlimmer werden
dass dieser Krieg so schnell wie möglich
beendet wird und würden dann die
Kampfstation nicht gerade dabei helfen
also
alle friedens- und konfliktforscher sind
sich darin einig dass immer mehr Waffen
nicht dazu beitragen ein ein Konflikt zu
beenden und darf ich mal kurz darf ich
mal kurz zu Ende reden und mir ist noch
ein Punkt wichtig der bezieht sich auch
auf sie haben Masala
ich finde ihre Argumentation wirklich
verkürzt denn sie dürfen ja nicht
übersehen wenn so ein Kampfjet
irgendetwas anrichtet auf russischem
Boden dann geht es ja nicht nur darum
was er faktisch dort tut ob er überhaupt
Ziele erreicht Menschen tötet oder sonst
etwas sondern von dem Moment an ist
Putin mit seinem narrativ das ist der
große vaterländische Krieg gegen den
Westen da ist der sofort auf der
sicheren Seite das was er einem Großteil
seiner Bevölkerung jetzt schon immer ein
bläude wo aber noch genügend Skeptiker
im Land sind das hätte sofort eine reale
Basis und das ist die Gefahr
also erstens stimmt das mit den
friedensoren pflichtforscher nicht also
es gibt eine einhelljenigen die ich
würde mal sagen
das ist immer eine nette wollte ernst zu
nehmen sie können mit Frau deitel auf
reden ich glaube eine der wichtigsten
und ernst zu nehmen sind Frieden zum
konfliktforscherinnen die es in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland gibt und die
wird Ihnen genau sagen in der jetzigen
Situation ist es zentral die Logik der
Russischen Föderation umzudrehen nämlich
die Logik die besagt von einer
Fortführung des Konfliktes nicht mehr
gewinnen zu können als zu verlieren und
dazu zählen Waffenlieferung was sie
sagen mit der Frieden zum
Konfliktforschung das entbehrt jeglicher
Basis denn die von denn die vernünftigen
denn die vernünftigen argumentieren
genauso der zweite Punkt ist
da eine Minderheiten Meinung und die
kommt aus einer sozusagen sehr
jetzt könnte was sie tun machen
ich habe große Sympathien für die
Friedensforschung aber was sie sagen
stimmt faktisch nicht und es tut mir
leid ich komme aus diesem aus diesem
Metier von daher kenne ich mich ein
bisschen besser
was anderes sagen sie würden sagen
dieser Krieg muss militärisch oder kann
nur militärisch beendet werden nein
dieser Krieg sozusagen es gibt eine
Zusammenhang zwischen Kriegslogik und
verhandlungslogik nämlich Verhandlungen
setzen dort ein wo Ergebnisse des
Schlachtfeldes sind und werden auf der
Basis der Ergebnisse des Schlachtfeldes
geführt wenn Verhandlungen jetzt
einsetzen dann reden wir über vier
annektierte Oblaste und die besetzte
Grimm das ist das Ergebnis je mehr die
Ukraine zurückerobert desto mehr
sozusagen wird bei der Verhandlungen das
Heft sich zur Seite der Ukraine neigen
ich will jetzt nur eine Sache sagen wir
haben die gleiche Logik mit der
Eskalation von Monaten gehört mit den
Kampfpanzern was kann Putin dann machen
und Putin wird Nuklearwaffen einsetzen
wo sind die Nuklearwaffen er hat sie
nicht eingesetzt abwarten bis die kommen
nein will ich nicht ich will nur sagen
diese Logik diese sozusagen
passieren die ist nicht gegeben wäre
dann in der Logik wenn man dann die
Logik weiter setzt dass man immer mehr
militärische Unterstützung wäre dann die
Logik nicht dass man sagt und irgendwann
wenn die Ukraine nicht mehr genug
Soldaten hat müssen wir auch
Bodentruppen schicken nein das ist ja
der faule Kompromisse wir machen das ist
die rote Linie die wir wirklich haben
wir werden uns sozusagen als NATO
starten in diesem Konflikt aktiv mit
eigenen Soldaten kämpfen die engagieren
das ist klar das will keiner und das
wird keiner es wird auch keiner machen
okay Herr Liebmann da bin ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht ihrer Meinung Herr Masala
und das liegt weniger in militärischen
Aspekten und mehr an der Logik des
autoritären Regimes in Russland und das
ist glaube ich das entscheidende die
Regime Handeln nicht unbedingt in der
rationalen Logik diese präsentieren sie
anderen primär aus den Logik der eigenen
Überleben weiß der Konflikt weiter
eskaliert und das ist tatsächlich eine
Situation die dann passieren würde wenn
Bomben auf dem russischen Boden fallen
wenn es wieder ein Angriff auf krimit
gibt da gibt's verschiedene
Interpretationen was da passiert ist
aber
falls wir regelmäßige Beschüsse der
russischen Krieg äh Grenzregion haben
die wir tatsächlich heute haben dann
werden früher oder später tatsächlich
zwei Prozesse Einsetzen der erste sie
haben dazu absolut zu Recht gesprochen
ist die Mobilisierung der russischen
Bevölkerung es ist erschreckend wie
schnell die Meinung von Leuten in
Russland sich dann ändern kann und dann
bekommen wir eine Situation wo wir nicht
nur in diesem Krieg sondern für
wahrscheinlich Jahrzehnte danach mit
einem aktiv aggressiv Anti westlichen
Russland zu tun haben werden das ist die
blockierte en
Jahrzehnte das ist sehr starke Position
von China also wir bekommen dann so ein
Konfliktsituation dessen negative
folgende gar nicht abschätzen können und
das zweite ist natürlich so eine
Eskalation wird auch die Logiken von
putinenden den Putin geht es primär
nicht um Kalkulation von militärischen
Gewinnen und Verlusten Putin geht's
primär um Existenz von seinem Regime und
falls er davon ausgehen wird dass die
militärische Niederlage komplette
militärische Niederlage ihn als
Machthaber in Frage setzen wird wird ja
alles einsetzen um sie zu vermeiden auch
wenn es militärisch keinen Sinn macht
und sie wissen was sie antwortet der USA
sein wird die ganz klar ist es eine gute
Lösung ich sag nicht dass es keine gute
Lösung ist aber das ist die
abschreckende Wirkung
das ist die abschreckende Wirkung
deswegen hat die Russische Föderation
bisher noch keinerlei nur klar aber von
eingesetzt aber weil selbst die großen
Unterstützer der Russischen Föderation
danke das weiß ich da war selbst die
größten Unterstützer der Russischen
Föderation Ch und Indien den Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen dezidiert verurteilen und
das ist der Grund warum bisher noch
keine Nuklearwaffen eingesetzt worden
sind putinette gute strategische Chancen
gehabt das zu tun und er hätte damit
sogar Effekte erzielt die verhindert
hätten dass wir Waffen geliefert hätten
er hat es nicht gemacht ist ein absolut
willkürliches Regime nein
welche Rolle spielt diese Diskussion
auch die also die Sorge dass Russland
war das ist eskaliert in der Ukraine und
wie sehr es gibt zum einen die
militärische Stärke auf der anderen
Seite ja die Frage nach dem durchhalte
Willen der Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine die
jetzt sehr sehr tapfer die ganze Zeit
waren gibt es da eine Bewegung wo man
merkt es gibt einfach auch so eine
Müdigkeit und Erschöpfung dass man sagt
der Krieg muss einfach schnell wie
möglich beendet werden und dafür sind
wir auch bereit irgendetwas aufzugeben
uns glaube ich alle einig in der Ukraine
auch in ukrainischen Bevölkerung dass
der Krieg so schnell wie möglich beendet
werden muss aber das bedeutet dass die
Territorien zum ersten Schritt befreit
werden dass sich die russischen Truppen
zurückziehen keine Angriffe mehr
stattfinden und bis dahin sind ist die
ukrainische Bevölkerung immer noch so
weit zu gehen dass sie weiterkämpft und
wir sehen zum Beispiel in bachmut dass
die russische Armee seit August
mindestens versuchtbachmut einzunehmen
und sie kann es nicht deswegen finde ich
dieses Argument der Eskalation
eigentlich nun die russische Armee
stellt sich nicht gerade besonders
geschickt da wir haben die Schlacht um
Kiew gewonnen wir haben hakiv befreien
können wir haben Herr Zorn befreien
können und obwohl Russland diese vier
diese oblasste
eingenommen also annektiert hat
völkerrechtswidrig und die Ukraine
trotzdem offensiven gegen diese Region
erfolgreich gefahren hat und eingenommen
hat es ist kein nuklearer Eskalation
gekommen obwohl es diese diese Annexion
gab es ist wird als Argument des Krems
immer wieder genutzt um uns in
Westeuropa vor allem zu verängstigen zu
sagen dass wir genau diese diese
Diskussion hier führen können das ist
ein gezieltes das Information des immer
wieder genutzt wird und auf dem viele
Leute anspringen aber es hat keine es
hat keinen keine Substanz wie gesagt
China und Indien sind gegen den Einsatz
von Nuklearwaffen und auf die beiden ist
Russland angewiesen ja lebt man wie
schätzen sie denn jetzt die die Stärke
des russischen Militärs ein das ist eine
große Frage das wissen wir eigentlich
jetzt nicht zuletzt deswegen bei den
Informationen nicht gegeben ist von dem
was ich weiß und ich bin anders als sie
kein militär-experte mein Fokus ist
Vergleich in der Politik und
Funktionsweise von autoritären Regimen
ist russische Militär zumindest aus
einer Sicht auf jeden Fall kampffähig
sie kann nach wie vor die menschlichen
Ressourcen ziehen putzen versucht die
zweite mobil machen zu vermeiden aus
politischen Gründen aber und das ich
kann nicht zu diesem Punkt nicht
zurückkehren das muss ich wirklich
machen alle Arten von Logiken die von
Russland als eine Identität als eine
Gesamtheit ausgehen
ignorieren den Tatbestand das ist am
Ende eine Gruppe von
Entscheidungsträgern geht den es um ihr
eigenes Schicksal geht wenn Putin der
Wahl stehen wird entweder verliere ich
morgen die Macht und dann gehe ich nach
Den Haag oder werde erschossen oder geh
ins Gefängnis oder
eigentlich alles andere steht auf der
anderen Waage als rechtfertigt und da
können wir keine da können wir leider
nicht stressig sicherheitspolitischer
argumentieren sondern innenpolitisch
okay der dieser Söldner Chef dieser von
dieser wagnergruppe brigoshi der hat ja
weiß schon sehr wütend hat gesagt man
kriegt zu wenig militärische
Unterstützung also gibt's irgendwo Punkt
wo man sieht da da bröckelt die
Unterstützung für Putin das ist eine
sehr schwierige Situation mit rigorien
es ist ein Akteur der im Wettkampf gegen
andere russische Akteure ist ganz
konkret gegen die Militär und
möglicherweise auch eigene politische
Ambitionen hat und da hat er sich
tatsächlich versucht den letzten Monaten
und Wochen extrem aktiv zu werden machen
es gab sogar ein Video wo er angeblich
so kaputt sind persönlich nicht direkt
aber indirekt angegriffen hat was er ein
Tag später zurückgenommen hat aber sah
fast so aus
trikotin per se ist zumindest aus meiner
Sicht nicht unbedingt die gefährlichste
Figur in dem was jetzt in der russischen
Politik abläuft im Vergleich zu dem zu
der ganzen Truppe weniger Soldaten ja
aber das zentrale ist es ist ja so die
wir können hier in Berlin spekulieren
wie die Lage in russischen Eliten ist
aber die Wahrheit ist leider wenn es
jetzt in den russischen Eliten bröckelt
und wenn es da Gruppen gibt die deutlich
aktiveren militärischen Kurs wollen wir
werden dann erst dann erfahren wenn sie
handeln es ist die Natur der Autokratien
sind in transparent ich bin nur auf
einen anderen Punkt kommen wir über
Wendepunkte mögliche Wendepunkte
sprechen dann sollten wir auch über den
NATO-Beitritt sprechen selenski hat das
bei der verlangnis karlspreises ja auch
noch mal ganz deutlich angesprochen dass
wir also dass er den die dass er in die
Nato will wie sinnvoll wäre das von mir
das geht gar nicht also die EU ist
natürlich
genau die richtige Option aber NATO geht
gar nicht denn ich meine Einnahmen sind
auch als Grenzländer also ja aber sie
gehörten immer immer selbst ganz
selbstverständlich zum Westen und sie
waren in ihrer Neutralität immer nach
Westen orientiert und nicht nach oder
auch von Union angegriffen aber dennoch
wenn die Ukraine zum NATO zur NATO
gehören würde wäre das wieder auf einer
anderen Ebene ein eine Form der
Eskalation die sich Russland einfach
nicht bieten lassen würde und also ich
wiederhole nur nicht gerne eine
Argumentation von Sahra Wagenknecht er
im Gegenteil aber wenn sie gestern im
Deutschlandfunk sagte naja man muss sich
das mal vorstellen wenn
China zum Beispiel
auf Kuba irgendwelche
waffenstationieren würde oder sonst
etwas was würden die Amerikaner dann
wohl machen das ist ein Platz ist
Argument aber
ja es ist relativ platt finde ich auch
aber um es zu verdeutlichen glaube ich
hilft es hilft es dennoch also
es wird auch nicht passieren mit der
NATO es wird auch nicht passieren denn
das muss sein wie wir wissen und schon
deswegen wird es nicht passieren
zustimmen Masala warum sollte die
Ukraine Mitglied der NATO werden also
zunächst einmal ich glaube auch dass es
jetzt auf diesen Gipfel in Litauen in
der Hinsicht sozusagen keine Bewegung
geben wird also die berühmte 2008 Formel
die wird so bestehen bleiben aber man
wird sozusagen kein genaues Datum nennt
für die Ukraine wenn man sich das aber
die Frage stellen ja die 2008 Formel
also 2008 wollte die
botschaftsministration Georgien und dann
damit auch die Ukraine aber es ging
eigentlich um Georgien sofort in die
NATO aufnehmen Deutschland und
Frankreich waren dagegen und haben als
Kompromiss vorgeschlagen die Formel
Georgien und Ukraine werden eines Tages
Mitglieder der NATO werden und das war
der Kompromiss um das auf die lange Bank
zu schieben
ich glaube es wird keine Bewegung in
Litauen geben weil so wie ich das sehe
zumindestens Deutschland und Frankreich
da ja noch sehr skeptisch sind aber wenn
man sich die Frage stellt warum es
sinnvoll ist dann geht das natürlich auf
die Frage läuft das auf die Frage hinaus
wie sieht die Zukunft der Ukraine nach
dem Ende des Krieges aus egal wie dieser
Krieg beendet wird also ob die Ukraine
es schafft sozusagen ihr Territorium
komplett zurückzubekommen oder ob das
dieser Krieg so endet dass die Russische
Föderation auf Territorium Brocken
bleibt und für dauerhaft besetzt dann
ist ja die Frage weil wir davon ausgehen
dass dieses Regime eine Agenda hat ja
das ist umsetzen will und letzten Endes
ein paar Jahren eine taktische Pause
haben wird um danach wieder den Versuch
zu unternehmen weiterzugeben also ist
die Frage wo kriegt die Ukraine
Sicherheit Garantie her und bei alldem
egal wie man es dreht ist die härteste
Sicherheitsgarantie besteht in einem
NATO-Beitritt alle anderen
Sicherheitsgarantien sind nicht so hart
sonst wäre die Alternative dass die
Ukraine deutlich dass er an der Seite
der Ukraine steht reicht das nicht das
reicht nicht sie hatten die Ukraine hat
das Trauma des Budapester Memorandums in
dem drei Staaten gesagt haben sozusagen
wenn deine Souveränität gebrochen wird
dann eilen wir dir zur Hilfe die
Souveränität wurde gebrochen und die USA
und Großbritannien haben nichts gemacht
also Verträge werden da nicht
weiterhelfen es braucht eine harte
Garantie und warum sagt eigentlich
Unsinn erzählt ist dass kein Mensch über
die Stationierung von Raketen in der
Ukraine nachdenkt das ist ein Argument
von Sahra Wagenknecht seit dem ersten
Tag des Krieges und da hat es nie
irgendeine Bewegung gegeben wie wichtig
wäre das aus ihrer Sicht dass die
Ukraine Tornado gehört für uns wäre das
sehr wichtig und über 80% der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung befürworten das
auch derzeit und es wäre deswegen
wichtig weil die Ukraine ja gerade für
Demokratie und für Freiheit kämpft also
eigentlich für Werte für die die NATO
dafür auch die die EU gut ja stehen
eigentlich und wenn wir betrachten was
würde wenn die Ukraine verliert was ich
nicht glaube ist dass der nächste
Schritt wäre Russland würde seine Pläne
in Moldau umsetzen Belarus läuft gerade
schon dass das mehr eingegliedert wird
und auch in Georgien hat Russland ja
Interessen es gibt ein frozenkonflikt
auch dort vor Ort das heißt es
beschränkt die Interessen von Russland
beschränken sich nicht nur auf der
Ukraine auf die Ukraine und deswegen
muss man sich überlegen wie weit gehen
wir denn mit dass wir starten wie die
Ukraine die souverän sind die eigene
Grenzen haben entmächtigen und sagen wir
uns interessiert mehr was der Aggressor
möchte aber können sie verstehen dass in
Putins Logik dass die größere Bedrohung
ist und das damit dann auch sozusagen
wieder eine Bedrohung ist glaube dass
die ganze NATO Erweiterung als Argument
ein vorgeschobener Grund ist weil sonst
hätte er sich bei Finnland das auch
nicht einfach so hingenommen weil es ist
auch an der russischen Grenze es ist ein
vorgeschobener Grund der hat sie das
Ziel dieses Krieges sind Neo koloniale
und Neo imperiale Interessen die weiter
ausgebaut werden sollen und darum
konkret ist also erstens bin ich sehr
vorsichtig bei den Aussagen das Russland
eine dauerhafte imperiale Agenda
verfolgt also echte empirische Evidenz
dafür haben wir nicht wir haben den
Krieg gegen Georgien wo allerdings
müssen wir ganz ehrlich sagen Saka
Schwede einen nicht unwesentlichen Teil
daran gespielt hat das ist zu diesem
Krieg kam und wir haben die Beteiligung
von Russland einen großen globalen
Konflikten wo Syrien in die sie aber
sehr viele andere Länder eingemischt
haben was wir wirklich haben ist und als
formuliere ich wirklich ganz genau so
persönliche Besessenheit von Putin mit
der Ukraine das ist genau ein wichtiger
Grund warum wir das beobachten was wir
jetzt beobachten wir haben ein System
das den Oberhaupt hat der wirklich
völlig irrsinnige historische Konzepte
entwickelt hat und das ist das zweite
was hier wichtig ist dein System dass
diesen Staatsoberhaupt nicht
einschränken können das ist aber auch
die entscheidende Frage über die
langfristigen Perspektiven falls der
Krieg bald vorbei sein wird darauf kann
man doch hoffen aber falls es bald sein
wäre dann besteht sehr große Chance dass
die neue Geschäftsführung dieser
persönliche Besessenheit von Putin nicht
teilen wird
das schon seit sehr langer Zeit diese
kolonialen koloniale Sichtweise auf die
Ukraine das hatten wir ein zahlreich das
hatten wir eine Sowjetunion wo die
Ukraine immer als interessensfeld oder
als kolonial klein Russland gesehen
worden ist das spiegelt sich in der
Literatur wieder das Spiel spiegelt sich
in der Kunst wieder das sehen wir auch
wenn wir mit Oppositionspolitikern von
Russland über die Ukraine sprechen dass
sie nicht als eigenständiges Subjekt
akzeptiert wird also empirisch ist es
nicht bestätigt wurde doch in der
nationalen Sicherheitsstrategie die
Ukraine unter anderem neben anderen
Staaten als das nahe Ausland
definiert in dem Russland eine ordnende
Funktion hat das war ja schon bei Jelzin
der Fall in der ersten nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie der Russischen
Föderation ich glaube wir müssen ein
bisschen
selbst wenn das wenn das so sein sollte
das Russland eben schon seit sehr langer
Zeit diese neoimperiale Agenda verfolgt
heißt es ja nicht dass sie das weiter
zum sobald der Besessene Weg ist weil da
gebe ich Ihnen natürlich völlig recht
sie brauchen ja immer eine treibende
Kraft und Russland hat noch ganz andere
Probleme wie wir wissen als nur Kriege
zu führen und deswegen ist es natürlich
die Frage selbst wenn es diese Agenda
gibt und die in vielen Köpfen rumspukt
sie voran und die Frage ist wird sie
vorangetrieben wenn es kein Putin mehr
gibt aber die Frage ist wenn sie vorhin
getrieben wird wenn es kein Problem mehr
gibt und die Ukraine keine
Sicherheitsgarantie hat was machen wir
denn dann
das ist keine Sicherheitsgarantie für
die Ukraine gibt es kann natürlich aber
in welcher Form in welcher Form wenn wir
über wenn wir über Verhandlungen reden
dann ist es doch ganz klar dass zu
solchen Verhandlungen auch
Sicherheitsgarantie dafür führen
wie wollen sie der Ukraine
Sicherheitsgarantien geben die Kiew und
der Bevölkerung sozusagen das Gefühl
geben man wird sich verteidigen wie
wollen sie die machen da würde ich jetzt
gerne Vorschlag halten also
Entschuldigung
wenn man in Verhandlungen reingeht zum
malt beim jetzigen Zeitpunkt dann redet
man erstmal drüber wie man überhaupt zu
Verhandlungen kommen und dann redet man
wie wollen Sie Sicherheit sie haben das
sie denken ja weil es eben einmal die
Sicherheit Garantien gehabt die da nicht
eingehalten worden dass das eben das
Problem ist durch das was wir Budapester
kommen wir jetzt mal auf Verhandlungen
wie wahrscheinlich ist denn das dass es
überhaupt zu Verhandlungen kommt wir
haben jetzt den ja es gibt Vorstöße der
chinesische Sondergesandte ist in K
eingetroffen da liegt man wo sehen sie
behaupten Ansatzpunkt für Verhandlungen
im Moment also es geht tatsächlich jetzt
sehr viel Aktivität die nicht von Europa
kommt es gibt auch eine Initiative der
afrikanischen Präsidenten die jetzt in
die Ukraine reisen werden und nach
Russland um da die Punkte anzustoßen ich
muss das wirklich sehr klar sagen
bedauerlicherweise sehe ich jetzt
kurzfristig keine Perspektive das ist zu
Verhandlungen führt das ist allerdings
wirklich bedauerlich und sobald das die
Situation ändern könnte auf einer von
den Seiten hätte man sofort diese
Möglichkeit ausnutzen müssen Frau lebe
wie wie sehr hofft man in der Ukraine
übersetzt man auf Verhandlungen oder ihr
haben sie ist es eher dieser Blick wir
müssen einfach diesen Krieg militärisch
gewinnen es gibt natürlich da
verschiedene Meinungen wenn man da auf
die Regierungsebene guckt selenski hat
einen 10 Punkte friedensformular
vorgestellt wo er Schritt für Schritt
erklärt was die Ukraine erwartet bis ein
Ende des Krieges so gesagt so gesehen
möglich ist da gehört
unter anderem dazu dass eben die Truppen
abgezogen werden
von gesamten Territorium das ist keine
Angriffe mehr gibt dass die Deportierten
Menschen zurückkehren können dass die
Kriegsgefangenen frei kommen und so
weiter also das sind zehn Punkte und
über die verhandelt werden kann also
über jeden einzelnen Punkt und es finden
auch derzeit immer noch Verhandlungen
zum Beispiel über das getreideabkommen
und über Kriegsgefangenen stand also es
ist eine Illusion das ist zurzeit gar
keine Verhandlungen gibt es gibt es gibt
Kanälen genau und wenn man über die Art
und Weise nachdenkt wie hier in
Deutschland zum Teil Verhandlungen
gefordert werden also dass man einfach
verhandelt und jetzt gibt's ein
Waffenstillstand das wird von der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung rigoros
abgelehnt also die Truppen müssen sich
zuerst aus der Ukraine zurückziehen ob
sie das freiwillig tun oder militärisch
dazu
gezwungen werden also es ist keine
Akzeptanz da dass ein frozen Konflikt
hingenommen werden würde von der
Bevölkerung
welche Chancen sehen Sie im Moment da
wenn es Initiativen aus China und Afrika
ist eigentlich ungewöhnlich dass Afrika
also ich glaube die
die Ergebnisse der ukrainischen
Offensive egal wie sie ausgehen wird
egal wie sie ausgehen wird die werden
ein neues Fenster öffnen sollte diese
Offensive scheitern glaube ich wird
sozusagen der Druck aus Washington
zunehmen weil Washington sich in dann
schon mitten im
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf findet und die
Demokraten wollen sozusagen den
Republikanern keine offene Flanke geben
dass diese Offensive jetzt ziemlich
lange dauert genau richtig was ich für
eine Katastrophe halten würde aber ich
glaube politisch wird so ausgehen sollte
die Ukraine erfolgreich sein und das
große Ziel die südliche von der
östlichen Front zu trennen und damit den
Druck auf die Krim zu erhöhen dann
glaube ich auch wird sich etwas tun im
Moskau ja aber es wird alles sozusagen
ich vermute mal erst 20 24 sein und
nicht 20 23 23
[Musik]
im Moment für Verhandlung also ich
glaube solange wir nicht anfangen
überhaupt aus der militärischen Logik
ein Stück rauszutreten und uns daneben
daneben zu stellen sondern so zu
argumentieren wie sie nach dem Motto das
wird erstmal auf den Schlachtfeld
entschieden und dann gucken wir mal
weiter was es für Möglichkeiten für
Behandlung ich glaube so geht es nicht
ich glaube wir müssen alles tun
damit überhaupt über die Voraussetzung
für Verhandlungen nachgedacht werden
kann und ich fürchte da muss auch die
Ukraine eine bestimmte Form der
Offenheit haben da kann es etwas wäre
dann das kann Verhandlungen statt die
ganze Zeit über verschiedene Punkte ja
über verschiedene Punkte und das ist ja
auch gut dass es diese das ist diese
Kanäle gibt ich glaube nur nicht also
ich bin keine militär-expertin aber ich
glaube nicht dass es dass die
Voraussetzungen für Verhandlungen
überhaupt geschaffen werden können wenn
eine Seite mit einem zehn Punkteplan
kommt obwohl ich jeden einzelnen einzeln
dieser Punkte unterschreiben
unterschreiben würde das ist eine ganz
andere Geschichte nur in Verhandlungen
muss man trotzdem relativ offen
reingehen und das halten müsste die
Ukraine Ihrer Meinung nach die Krim
Russland zugestehen oder Teile nein nein
alles nur in Verhandlungen gelöst werden
die wie das wie das Endergebnis dann
aussieht mit Offenheit meine ich dass
man nicht mit einer Agenda in solche
Verhandlungen reingehen kann und ich
finde
man muss wissen was man will aber
die Guten und die Bösen aber wir wissen
doch im Moment genau wer die Guten und
die Bösen sind die guten sind die
Ukrainer in die Bösen sind sind die
Russin die müssen irgendwann an einen
Tisch kommen und dazu braucht es
sozusagen zum Eindruck von außen und der
Westen hat eine große Verantwortung wer
sich so engagiert auch mit Waffen ist
auch mit dafür verantwortlich dass
dieser Krieg irgendwann beendet werden
kann
ganz gut weil sie ständig über die
Ukraine reden sie haben auf der anderen
Seite eine Akteur Russland der in jedem
kommunizier sagt wir gehen sofort an den
Verhandlungstisch wenn man die
territorialen Realitäten akzeptiert das
heißt genauso ja aber dann erwähnen sie
auch die andere Seite deswegen ist der
Punkt dass es momentan wir sind bei
Verhandlungen
brauchen sie Akteure die
verhandlungsbereit sind und die haben
wir momentan nicht wir wissen sozusagen
aus der Empirie wann Akteure
verhandlungsbereit sind das sind beide
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt auch nicht die
Verantwortung kommt auch von allen
UnterstützerInnen
ständig Dialog es ist doch nicht so dass
sozusagen ist man nicht redet es werden
Verhandlungen sogar vorbereitet was ich
sehr gut finde weil ich glaube diese
Verhandlungen werden extrem lange dauern
und extrem schwierig werden so dass man
sie jetzt schon anfängt vorzubereiten es
ist ein Mythos zu sein dass diese
militärlogik Verhandlungen nicht immer
dann doch der dass es um die besetzten
Gebiete geht und um die Krim das ist
natürlich letztendlich dann doch darum
dreht und dann sagen sie ja aus ihrer
sich das ist für uns also nicht
verhandelbar
haben also ich muss zuerst hinzufügen
dass es Verhandlungen seit 2014 gibt der
Krieg geht nicht erst seit letzten Jahr
da geht seit 2014 es gab Runden um
Runden nur jedes Jahr gab es
Verhandlungsrunden mit Deutschland mit
dabei im normalen die Format mit
Frankreich mit dabei die sind alle
gescheitert das minsker-abkommen eins
und zwei sind gescheitert und es gab
diese Verhandlungsbereitschaft sogar in
den ersten Tagen des Krieges wo man nur
gesagt hat man kann noch mal diskutieren
man geht vielleicht zu den Grenzen von
dem 24 Februar sogar zurück was jetzt
mittlerweile vom Tisch ist ähm von der
ukrainischen Seite aber es gab eine
enorm große Verhandlungsbereitschaft auf
der ukrainischen Seite bis Botschafter
und wenn man Massengräber findet wenn
man erschossene Menschen auf der Straße
findet dann wenn man weiß was in diesen
besetzten Gebieten passiert dann kann
man nicht hinnehmen dass diese diese
Gebiete besetzt bleiben egal wie es ist
einfach eine Realität dass diese
Menschen unglaublich schlimmes jeden Tag
erfahren in Herford in lug
auf der Krim und das können wir nicht
akzeptieren aus einer ukrainischen
Perspektive und deswegen muss das
Schicksal von diesen Menschen die vor
Ort sind immer im Vordergrund stehen
Herr lebt man was gibt es irgendeine
Position die Russland bewegen könnte
also wenn wir jetzt hören eben aus China
gibt es Initiative eben diese sechs
Staaten aus Afrika das sind Südafrika
Sambia Senegal Kongo Uganda und Ägypten
also haben die eine Chance also in
Russland etwas zu bewirken na ja die
zentrale Frage ist natürlich worüber man
genau verhandelt und da muss ich leider
tatsächlich zustimmen wenn man von
Anfang an sagt dass die einzige
behandlungsposition die für die Ukraine
akzeptabel ist der völlige Rücktritt von
Russland von allen besetzten Territorien
inklusive die Krim das ist auch aus
vielerlei Hinsicht ein schwieriges
Problem weil wir haben auf der Krim eine
nicht erheblichen Teil der Bevölkerung
dass sich jetzt zum heutigen Zeitpunkt
zu Russland identifiziert
dann kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass
es Verhandlungen geben wird wo dieser
Punkt als gegeben einer akzeptiert wird
aber ich glaube auch nicht dass es der
Punkt es den die afrikanischen oder die
chinesischen gesamten versuchen jetzt
Russland zu vermitteln also das zentrale
Problem ist leider tatsächlich und da
muss ich leider zugeben ich bin sehr
pessimistisch wir haben so stark wie wir
gierende Vorstellungen davon wie
Konflikt abgeschlossen werden kann
sodass wir am Ende
ja also wir müssen nicht unbedingt davon
ausgehen dass es Verhandlungen geben
kann die eine stabile und langfristige
Lösung finden
es liegt an der Besessenheit von putinen
mit der Ukraine dann wirkt das ja so da
da gegen diese besessen dann kommt man
doch dann sowieso nicht naja man kann
einiges damit machen und das ist genau
der Punkt warum ich persönlich der
Meinung bin dass die Verhandlungen
obwohl ich das skeptisch bin durchaus
wichtig und notwendig sind und da würde
ich ihn voll zustimmen dass je früher
sie Anfang desto besser Putins Regime
hat ja aus biologischen Gründen ein
begrenztes albdauer er wird früher
später die machtspitze in Russland
verlassen und es kann aber noch dauern
ja aber genau die Präsidenten
aber wir stehen jetzt gerade an dem
kritischen Punkt falls es jetzt
geschehen werde gelingen wird diesen
Konflikt einzufrieren sogar
vorübergehend wird die russische
Bevölkerung nach wie vor passiv bleiben
und die russischen Eliten werden passiv
bleiben das heißt es wird ein Fenster
nach dem Gehen von Putin sicher eröffnet
falls der Konflikt noch mehrere Jahre
dauert das ist eine realistische Option
kommt irgendwann zu Punkt wo die
russische Bevölkerung auch
nationalistisch mobilisiert sein wird
und dann wird gar keine Möglichkeiten
mehr geben dann haben wir eine
Trennlinie in Europa die wir ja sogar zu
stellenistischen Zeiten in der Form
nicht gesehen haben
wie möglich beenden müssen und dafür
genauso so viele Waffen liefern müssen
damit die Ukraine gewinnen kann damit
die damit die Russen sich nicht weiter
radikalisieren also in ihrem ihrer Logik
entsprechend müsste darauf ja eigentlich
folgen dass wir mehr und schneller
Waffen liefern aber da entsteht Problem
das glaubwürdigen versprechen woher
wissen wir dass die ukrainische Seiten
die Waffen nicht verwenden wird auf dem
russischen
Zentren auch in Russland angegreifen
aber sie haben also Sie haben ja in
mehreren Phasen Heimat Maß 2 je nachdem
wo man die positioniert kommt man auch
mit den 70 Kilometern sozusagen auf
russisches Territorium sie haben ja
mehrfach diese Versprechen abgeben
müssen und jetzt glaube ich auch als er
hier in Berlin gemacht hat und bislang
haben sie sich dran gehalten sie haben
zwar Ziele in Russland angegriffen ja
völkerrechtlich völlig legitim also in
der Grenzregion aber sie haben sich
bisher dran gehalten weil sie wissen sie
verlieren die Unterstützung des Westens
sie verlieren die Unterstützung des
Wissen liefern dann ist das schön und
gut aber irgendwann hat diese 16 keine
Bomben mehr und dann kommen die Ukraine
sondern die brauchen aus dem Westen in
dem Moment in dem Sie vielleicht schon
zu spät wir hatten als Eingangsfrage für
diese Sendung ja die Frage wann kommt
der Wendepunkt also wie schätzen Sie das
ein jetzt noch mal hier zum Schluss in
der als Schlussfrage was auf was denken
sie müssen wir uns vom zeitlichen
Horizont einstellen für diesen Konflikt
also ich kann da eigentlich nur eine
Hoffnung formulieren denn das Problem
ist ja und das wurde ja hier bei unserer
Diskussion auch sehr deutlich je mehr
Opfer es gibt
desto schwieriger ist das Ende eines
Konflikts und überhaupt die Idee von
Verhandlungen deswegen habe ich die
Hoffnung dass es das Fenster zu
verhandeln so schnell wie möglich gibt
ich kann es nur hoffen
weil ich teile zum großen Teil ihres
Skepsis aber je länger dieser Krieg
dauert desto größer werden die Gräben
desto mehr Tote verwundete verstümmelte
verschleppte Menschen gibt es und also
es ist eine Hoffnung aber
ich befürchte ich muss dem Teil die die
Einsicht Teilen ich würde auch sehr
hoffen dass die Verhandlungen so bald
wie möglich anfangen und ich bedauere
sehr dass Deutschland jetzt leider nicht
in der Position da ist irgendwas zu
unternehmen also am Ende wird es an die
den globalen Süden kommen die
Vermittlerrolle zu übernehmen befürchte
aber dass es tatsächlich realistische
enorme Gefahr gibt dass der Krieg noch
sehr lange gedauert
ich kann mich dem nur anschließen ich
glaube sozusagen realistischerweise der
Krieg und noch lange dauern
ich denke das hört auf hängt davon ab
wie viel Waffen die Ukraine bekommt wie
schnell sie die bekommt und es ist aus
einer ukrainischen Perspektive machbar
wenn man das Werkzeug dazu bekommt die
militärischen Realitäten soweit
voranzubringen dass man das Moskau
verhandeln muss und ich denke das ist
durchaus möglich das ist auch dieses
Jahr vielleicht möglich aber es hängt
von der Unterstützung des Westens ab und
da hoffen wir als ukrainische
Gemeinschaft in Deutschland aber auch
viele Ukraine und Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine drauf vielen Dank Frau Lehrer
Masala formika und für diese Diskussion
vielen dank ihnen fürs zuschauen jetzt
folgt Phoenix der Tag mit Thomas Bade
und ich sag tschüss das war die Phönix
Runde in dieser Woche wünsche Ihnen
einen schönen Feiertag bis dann tschüss
[Musik]